[Musique]
voilà un fond intox avec Antoine fenaud
ce soir Antoine bonsoir On va prendre ce
soir la direction du Mali où certains
internautes pensent avoir trouvé des
profs du soutien de la France au groupe
djihadiste oui absolument c'est une
affirmation qui a beaucoup circulés
notamment sur Twitter ces derniers jours
notamment avec une vidéo que je vous
montrerai un petit peu plus tard dans
mon intervention le tweet lui par
exemple le voici c'est quelques trucs
comme ça qui ont circulé donc sur
Twitter une preuve vous le voyez que la
jungle français soutient le terrorisme
au Mali avec donc une vidéo vous
l'apercevez qui fait 30 secondes elle a
été vu un peu plus de 13000 fois un
autre exemple de tweet ou qui reprend
stricto-sensuit exactement la même
rhétorique un toujours cette même vidéo
la beaucoup moins vu évidemment qu'il
s'agit d'un autre compte avec encore une
fois cette affirmation de jeunes
françaises qui soutient le terrorisme
donc la vidéo elle la voici elle est
assez mauvaise qualité il y a un petit
habillage dessus mais ce qui nous
intéresse vous le voyez c'est ce qu'on y
voit on y voit donc des militaires
français ça c'est vrai qu'on peut
l'affirmer des chargeurs de des armes
donc qu'ils vont ensuite transmettre
vous allez le voir c'est en tout cas ce
qui affirme le contexte de la vidéo on
va le voir un petit peu un petit peu
plus loin dans le dans la vidéo voilà
avec cet homme que vous apercevez ici en
turbant et un militaire français donc
lui remet un sac jaune ce qui fait dire
donc à ses internautes donc et bien la
France fournit des armes à des
terroristes normalises la vidéo a
également circulé beaucoup sur des
groupes WhatsApp au Mali là là c'est
carrément c'est sans équivoque vous
voyez la France égale terroriste voilà
donc pour ces affirmations claires le
problème c'est que c'est faux il suffit
d'un détail d'ailleurs pour ça on
apercevoir absolument et pour pour se
faire je vous remontre le premier tweet
que je vous ai montré avec une capture
de d'écran de la vidéo vous voyez le
petit logo ici en haut à droite de cette
vidéo c'est AP nous le journaliste on
les connaît bien ce logo il fait
référence à l'agence américaine
associative presse vu que la recherche
d'images inversée ne donne rien vous
savez que c'est un peu notre marotte ici
un fond intox la recherche d'image
inversée on est donc allé voir ce que ça
dans les archives de l'agence AP et on
est tombé sans surprise sur un reportage
vous le voyez ici j'ai fait une petite
petite capture d'écran pour vous le
montrer un reportage donc tourné au Mali
logiquement qui était tourné lui le 4
juillet 2015 donc rien à voir qui
s'appelle le long chemin vers le
désarmement au normalis la vidéo on l'a
également pu la retrouver sur Youtube
voici une capture d'écran également sur
le site toujours de la chaîne Youtube de
la et la chaîne officielle AP et vous
voyez là ce qui nous intéresse c'est le
temps de la vidéo elle fait 4 minutes 31
rien à voir donc avec les extraits d'une
trentaine de secondes que je vous ai
montré et la vidéo en elle-même et bien
la voici c'est donc on y retrouve un peu
un point stricto-sins dessus quasiment
les mêmes images qu'on voit en tout cas
au début de la vidéo je vais avancer un
petit peu vous allez vous rendre compte
que c'est bien différent là on qu'est-ce
qu'on voit on voit des militaires
français qui saisissent des armes qui
font des inventaires de munitions
notamment et en fait il s'agissait d'une
mission conjointe après ton reportage
entre les forces armées maliennes à
l'époque et les militaires français pour
désarmer des groupes jihadistes souvent
certains venaient volontairement
remettre des armes d'autres et bien été
interceptés par l'armée française et il
voyait donc leurs armes saisies vous
voyez ici là quelqu'un qui disait voilà
est-ce que je vais pouvoir il dit dans
le reportage est-ce que je vais pouvoir
récupérer mon arme et le militaire
français lui répond il faudra que tu
retournes à Gao la ville du nord du Mali
pour le voir le reportage lui il a été
tourné justement pas loin de Gao vous le
voyez juste ici c'est ici dans la région
d'asongo c'est dans la fameuse zone on
la connaît bien nous ici à la zone des
trois frontières où il y a une intense
activité djihadiste entre le Burkina
Faso le Mali ici et le Niger et donc ce
reportage qui a été tourné ici voilà
donc claire et c'est pas la première
fois Antoine que c'est un fox anti
française surgissent au Mali et vous le
savez bien justement j'ai choisi pour
vous quelques petits exemples récents en
tout cas de ces infos ce qui illustre
bien cette rhétorique générale
anti-française et il faut bien le dire
également j'ai choisi deux exemples pour
vous qu'on avait notamment traité un
faux intox c'était le cas notamment vous
le voyez ici c'était le 14 décembre 2021
avec un exemple d'un soi-disant
hélicoptère qui l'a livré des armes au
normalis là encore même rhétorique ou
encore un petit peu encore en plus de
plus anciens ça c'était en 2019 en
décembre 2019 des images qui étaient
censé montrer un conteneur d'armes
arrivant pareil de la France pour
soutenir les djihadistes à l'époque au
normalis et plus récemment c'est une
rhétorique qui a été reprise même dans
la bouche même des autorités de la jante
il faut bien le dire avec notamment ses
affirmations du ministre des Affaires
étrangères maliens devant la tribune de
l'ONU qui accusait la France de soutien
de au terroristes donc voilà c'était
info intox merci beaucoup Antoine fenon
peut retrouver votre chronique bien sûr
sur notre site internet www.france24.com